THAT SUFFERED BEFORE YOU
FINALLY ARE ABLE TO DO IT AND
DO IT RIGHT?
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION WE
HAVE THE HOST OF MICHELLE
MALKIN INVESTIGATES FORMER
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
SEAN SPICER.
IT WAS 2009, MICHELLE, WHEN THE
RIGHT -- MANY ARE SIGNING A
STANDING OVATION.
THE PEOPLE RACING FOR THE NEXT
SAVIOR.
>> IN THE CLIP YOU JUST SHOWED,
AMONG THE PEOPLE WHO LEAPT TO
THEIR FEET FOR ROMAN POLANSKI
AND MERYL STREEP AND HARVEY
WEINSTEIN.
I HAVE TO DISAGREE WITH YOU
SLIGHTLY, SEAN, AS MUCH AS I'VE
HEARD --
>> Sean: WE'VE BEEN FAMILY FOR
YEARS.
>> SO I DO NOT JOIN IN ALL OF
THE EFFUSIVE PRAISE FOR OPRAH'S
SPEECH LAST NIGHT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS TEXTBOOK,
PARTISAN, AND IDEOLOGICAL
IDENTITY LIBERALISM AND SHE
HERSELF IS ONE WHO HAS BEEN
ACCUSED BY MULTIPLE VICTIMS OF
HARVEY WEINSTEIN OF BEING A
FIXER FOR HARVEY WEINSTEIN.
THERE ARE MANY INFAMOUS
PICTURES OF HER HANGING OFF OF
WEINSTEIN.
>> Sean: DID SHE KNOW?
WITH ME AND YOU OVER THE YEARS.
WE DON'T KNOW THEM.
>> NO QUESTION ABOUT IT BUT THE
CONSENSUS FROM SO MANY OF THE
WEINSTEIN FOR YEARS AND BEEN
IGNORED IS THAT QUOTE, UNQUOTE,
PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT OPRAH
WINFREY KNEW AS WELL.
SO LOOK, THE IDEA THAT
HOLLYWOOD AND DEMOCRAT
ALL OF THE GOSSIP ABOUT A
POTENTIAL RUN.
WHAT WOULD WE GET?
WE WOULD GET ANOTHER EIGHT
YEARS OF THE SAME KIND OF
BARACK OBAMA WHO HAS IN PART SO
LARGE A ROLE OF OPRAH WINFREY
AND LAST NIGHT ALL OF HOLLYWOOD
AND OPRAH WERE PRETENDING AS IF
THE LAST EIGHT YEARS OF THE
AND THAT'S TO ME I THINK WHAT
IS MOST TROUBLING.
THE UNREALITY OF THE PEOPLE IN
THE HOLLYWOOD BUBBLE.
>> Sean: SEAN, I GO BACK -- I
FELT IN MANY WAYS BETWEEN
VETTING OBAMA AND REVEREND
WRIGHT AND BLACK LIBERATION
THEOLOGY AND ACORN AND FRANK
MARSHALL DAVIS.
THERE WERE A FEW OF US,
MICHELLE WAS ONE.
A FEW OF US THAT VETTED HIM AND
ABOUT, WHAT WE HAD 13 MILLION
MORE AMERICANS ON FOOD STAMPS,
8 MILLION MORE IN POVERTY, THE
LOWEST LABOR PARTICIPATION RATE
SINCE THE 70s.
WORST RECOVERY SINCE THE 40s.
LOWEST HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE IN 51
YEARS AND GAVE IRAN $150
BILLION AND DOUBLED THE DEBT.
TRUTH, FACTS AND SUBSTANCE
MATTERS BUT I FEEL I WAS ALONE
HERE IN A LOT OF WAYS.
I HAD MICHELLE LIKE FAMILY TO
SO WHY THE RUSH FOR A SAVIOR
AGAIN WHEN THE LAST SAVIOR THEY
CHOSE FAILED SO MISERABLY?
>> LOOK, I THINK THE THING
THAT'S INTERESTING WHAT OPRAH
SAID LAST NIGHT ALL AMERICANS
RESPECTING WOMEN, CREATING A
SAFE WORK ENVIRONMENT IS
SOMETHING WE SHOULD ALL AGREE
ON.
IT SHOULD BE BEYOND POLITICS
AND ONIDEOLOGY.
SOMETHING THAT EVERY AMERICAN
AND HUMAN SUPPORTS.
THAT BEING SAID I THINK THE
INTERESTING THING LAST NIGHT
SHE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT HOW TO
SOLVE SOME OF THE MORE
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES.
TO YOUR POINT RIGHT NOW THEY
WE SHOULD ALL AGREE ON BUT THAT
YOU APTLY POINT OUT IS HIGHLY
HYPOCRITICAL TO THE PEOPLE IN
THAT ROOM.
IT IS BILL CLINTON AND OTHERS.
THEY HAVE GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK OUT.
THEY OVERLOOKED IT.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, YOU HAD TO
SIT IN A ROOM.
DID.
THINKING YOU KNOW, YOU REALLY
DIDN'T DO THAT MUCH WRONG
BECAUSE THEY WERE SO HOSTILE.
I CAN'T THINK OF A MOMENT THEY
HAVE GIVEN TRUMP A BREAK AND
THEY GAVE OBAMA EVERY BREAK.
BOTH BEFORE, DURING AND AFTER.
WHAT IS YOUR EXPERIENCE WITH
THE PRESS?
>> OH, LOOK, I HAVE KNOWN A LOT
OF THESE GUYS FOR MORE THAN TWO
DECADES.
THERE WAS UNBELIEVABLY A
MASSIVE HOSTILITY NEVER SEEN
BEFORE.
THE PEW CENTER BACKED IT UP.
63% OF THE COVERAGE AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS NEGATIVE.
ONLY 5% POSITIVE.
WHICH IS THREE TIMES WHAT THAT
WAS OF OBAMA.
THEY CAME OUT GUNS BLAZING IN
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
THERE WERE UPSET THAT THEY WERE
WRONG AND THEY WERE GOING TO
>> I THINK THAT HOLLYWOOD AND
THE DEMOCRATS NEED TO PUT DOWN
THE OPRAH BONG AND STOP
INHALING AND PROBABLY THE
REASON WHY THEY'RE SO DESPERATE
IS IF YOU LOOK AT THE CURRENT
ELIZABETH WARREN, YOU HAVE
BERNIE SANDERS, WHO WILL BE 79.
MAXINE WATERS WHO IS CAST AS
THE FRESH FACE OF THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY.